Marcel has a great voice which you
discovered you you sort of do that voice
and it became our selfish L do you do
that voice in real life I do I do it I
do it around the house now I kind of do
it like sometimes I do it when things
are going badly I find that like it'll
like spill something and I'm just like
that was so quiet I could it's so little
or but sometimes I do like motivational
stuff like okay you can do it that's
that small is not inspired
thanks to me like you can't do it well I
can do I do a lot of covers is like the
most the biggest thing that is like
going on with Marcel right covers yeah
like I recently did one of landslides
the classic that made my husband shed a
little tear really yeah landslides
Stevie Nicks singing Lance let you do it
as Marcel yeah and maybe he was crying
just cuz he was like Jenni's crazy she's
gone man but I think it's it's cuz it's
beautiful can we hear it is it okay if
we hear it
sure okay just a little bit I don't want
you have to pay
you guys are spending all that money on
gifts right or not
[Applause]
the mall buying more stuff okay this is
landslides as Marcel sings it up a
little snippet okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
big ones on that little snail yeah
you